bwin betclic unibet winamax pokerstars
ces noms ne vous disent peut-être rien
et pourtant déjà trois millions de
français jouent de l'argent sur internet
sur ses sites en ligue 1 on y trouve des
paris sportifs on parie sur des matches
de football de basket ou de tennis et du
poker en ligne le jeu hyper tendance en
deux trois clics on rentre ses
coordonnées sont le code d'accès la
carte bleue et ses terrasses en cinq
minutes si je veux dire c'est fait donc
c'est pour ça qu'on n'a pas forcément
conscience de jouer sur des sites
illégaux
c'est pas à plafonner peut jouer des
mises
à 2 2 $ cad dollars etc il ya même des
partis qui n'ont jusqu'à 1000 dollars
depuis la france vingt-deux mille sites
de jeux en ligne sont accessibles dont
un quart en français basé à malte à
gibraltar ou à londres
ils sont totalement illégaux aux yeux de
la loi française n'est contrôlé ni taxés
par l'état
on s'est dit qu'on pouvait pas laisser
la france comme ça avec une nulle des
sites illégaux
partout il y en a partout on peut pas
les contrôler et qu' il fallait prendre
en compte ce phénomène de jeu qu'il
fallait définir un cadre légal
permettant aux joueurs français d'y
avoir accès c'est ce que nous avons fait
le gouvernement a donc décidé de faire
une loi
en mars 2009 elle est présentée en
conseil des ministres et c'est eric
woerth alors ministre du budget qui sera
son promoteur
bienvenue dans les coulisses d'une loi
passée presque inaperçue
une loi qui touche autant aux aspects
financiers qu'à la santé et qui posera
plus de difficultés que le gouvernement
l'avait prévu
soirée unibet un opérateur de paris
sportifs bénéfice net en 2009 29
millions d'euros près de 300 mille
joueurs actifs
champagne et petits fours ce soir là ils
reçoivent les journalistes pour une
opération séduction dans quelques jours
comme vous le savez le débat
parlementaire va démarrer puisque c'est
le 7 et 8 octobre
on va parler d'un grand sujet que c'est
la libéralisation des secteurs des jeux
en ligne et donc des paris sportifs et
donc ce soir et bien vous allez pouvoir
participer à une soirée de paris live
c'est sûr qu'ils ont plus de chances de
lunettes vous aimez tant lui donner le
lieu a été bien choisi
l'opération se passe au parc des princes
le stade du paris saint-germain lecteurs
elle doit être des princes est pas tout
à fait un hasard puisque je crois que
c'est un secret de polichinelle on est
effectivement assez en relation assez
étroite avec le psg puisque normalement
à partir de l'ouverture du marché
nous serons le partenaire du psg et donc
notamment son partenaire maillot et en
plus du partenariat avec un club de
football
unibet a aussi négocié un partenariat
avec une radio nationale
c'est un partenariat qu'on a monté avec
notre partenaire rmc et on a monté
ensemble
finalement la première radio des pareils
tout est si bien organisée quand on en
oublierait presque un petit détail le
fait que vous soyez illégaux ça ça pose
pas un problème majeur
mais c'est encore une fois tout cas
l'interprétation sommes-nous illégaux je
crois que ces questions qui a encore pas
été véritablement tranché donc je pense
que de ce point de vue là les choses
sont assez claires et encore une fois on
est dans le processus législatif
les choses se font aujourd'hui on
discute avec les autorités je pense
qu'on a des choses à apporter au débat
manifestement les opérateurs ne vont pas
se gêner pour profiter de l'ambiguïté de
la situation au sénat françois trucy a
été désigné rapporteur de la loi pour la
commission des finances
c'est le spécialiste des jeux d'argent
au sénat pour recueillir le maximum
d'informations et affiner son opinion il
commence alors un marathon d'audition
j'ai voulu serrer un peu importants
d'audition 80 90 qui est à la fois les
nouveaux des nouveaux des petits
nouveaux de la classe les gros nouveau
de la classe et puis tout un toute une
palanquée de gens avec qui je travaille
sur les jeux depuis avant que ça on
parle de sa valeur depuis des années ce
que vous attendez de notre passé notre
compréhension de la loi et non
les mises des choses que vous êtes
quelqu'un qui sait très bien que ça
marchera pas c'est bien mais est ce que
vous avez pensé à ceux ci à 800 et
critique pas des principes mais des
détails fondamentaux françois trucy va
recevoir tous les acteurs du secteur
spécialistes associations et bien sûr
les opérateurs
ce jour là c'est l'audition de stéphane
courbit tu producteur de téléréalité est
désormais à la tête d'un site de paris
et pour défendre l'ouverture du marché
il martèle un argument de poids les
taxes que l'état va récupérer sur les
jeux en 2008 nous va juste betclic
on évalue à peu près un petit milliard
de miss qui ont été faites sur le marché
français pensaient taxés à 8 et demie
pourtant super 85 millions de taxes
potentiel perdrix paraître à penser on
est un des acteurs on est un des 1
certes parmi les leaders en veut dire
que les petit par dix le main la taille
du marché tiennent pas mais quatre ou
cinq déjà largement qu'une cinquième
rang en tout cas il ya plusieurs
centaines de millions d'euros le monde
qui nous est chère planète c'est tout
pareil qu'au delà des emplois créés
ça permet la création de valeur la
création de nouvelles entreprises la
création d'emplois à nous aujourd'hui ça
me remettre essentiel dans notre
économie de ne pas laisser filer ça on a
moyen aujourd'hui parce que nos écoles
sont excellentes en termes d'ingénieurs
formation d'avoir ici la création
d'emplois pour les jeunes
ça me semble dommage de laisser filer
c'est à nouveau à malte mon angleterre
aujourd'hui on pense que c'est un
secteur porteur qui a qui va créer de la
valeur et des emplois pour la france et
qui bien sûr
patron probablement nous permettent de
faire un petit peu de profit comme toute
entreprise privée nous sommes là pour ça
c'est tout à fait légitime de toute
façon que les gens défendent leur point
de vue c'est l'ours et leur pognon c'est
leur travail
par contre s'il est tout aussi légitime
quand on les écoute parce que comment
avoir la meilleure information si on
écoute pas tout le monde a peur on
écoute tout le monde mais on fait ce
qu'on veut ça n'enlève aucune liberté au
reporter par contre ça lui donne plus
d'informations ce qui est nécessaire et
d'une centaine d'auditions en tout
doctor bernard françois trucy recevra de
nombreux candidats à l'ouverture du
marché
et voici le représentant d'une
association européenne d'opérateur de
paris en ligne à qui il faut bien ré
expliquer le principe de la future loi
française la loi telle qu'elle est vue
du côté français elle est convenable
parce qu'elle en fait elles essayent de
protéger appelé monopole alors laisse
pas mal de choses elle essaie d'ouvrir à
des gens sérieux qui sont capables
demain elle essaye de protéger ses
ressources fiscales de l'état
en général quand on fait une loi qui
essaie de faire plaisir à tout le monde
ça fait plaisir à personne à nos côtés
donc c'est probablement ce qu'il va se
passer
mais je pense que les membres ont su la
maison de vous dire ce qu'il pense des
conditions économiques ces gens là ont
voulu pénétrer le marché français il ya
maintenant plusieurs années sans succès
jusqu'ici
ils ont fait une pression directe sur le
sur la commission européenne pour
qu'elle englobe la france ça c'est sûr
c'est un argument politique qui a été
avancé dans un premier temps qui
consiste à dire qu'effectivement le lit
slater français intervenaient sous la
pression de communautaire mais cette
pression n'existe pas il ya une chose
qui existe c'est qu'il ya eu des
questions posées par la commission
européenne à la france mais pas
seulement à la france à d'autres pays de
l'union européenne sur les questions
d'ailleurs très précises qui parle qui
concernait pas les les jeux en général
ni les jeux forcément en ligne en
particulier mais un problème de
reconnaissance entre états va
désagréments qui sont données d'un état
à l'autre
c'est d'être une question très précise
et la commission a d'ailleurs ajouté
à l'époque c'était le commissaire
européen ultra libéral charlie mccreevy
que les questions qui étaient posées
n'impliquait en rien la libéralisation
du marché même lui l'a dit donc c'est
très clair
en choisissant d'ouvrir son marché la
france mettra fin à un système qui
datent du 19e siècle
jusqu'ici les jeux d'argent était
confiée à trois monopoles d'état tous
lourdement taxées
la française des jeux pour les jeux de
hasard pur qui reversent une partie de
ses gains à des organismes de santé
publique et au sport amateur
le pmu qui finance toute la filière
hippique et les casinos l'ouverture du
marché à des opérateurs privés
c'est une vraie révolution qui aiguise
les appétits quitte pour certains
enfoncé la porte dans les mois qui
suivent des publicités pour des sites de
paris inondé la toile des publicités et
du sponsoring par anticipation comme l'a
fait le président de l'olympique
lyonnais jean michel aulas avec
l'opérateur betclic
l'olympique lyonnais qui souhaitait
faire de la publicité pour un site avant
la loi qui n'était pas autorisé ça c'est
pas réglé dans les tribunaux ça s'est
réglé en discutant avec le président de
l'ol en discutant avec le site en
question en particulier comme
comportement quand même on saisir et on
discute face à ce comportement là c'est
illégal
on discute pour que justement ce soit
pas illégal mais on sait qu' il ya une
intention de provocation illégal à ce
moment là on anticipe et puis on évite
que justement ça devienne illégal
d'ailleurs pas fait donc il ya pas eu d
l'égalité donc il ya bien une discussion
pour éviter cela on est dans une période
assez compliquée où des gens se
préparent sont prêtes à rentrer sur un
marché piaf un peu attendent un texte au
parlement
il ya un calendrier du parlement qui
fait que les choses peuvent pas venir
aussi vite qu'on le souhaiterait donc il
faut éviter les provocations c'est ce
qu'on fait présentation de la loi à la
presse et explications de sa mise en
oeuvre
la loi prévoit de légaliser certains
sites en leur délivrant des
autorisations payante et pour délivrer
ses licences une nouvelle autorité
administrative est créé l'arjel elle
n'existe pas encore mais elle a déjà son
président jean françois vilotte
vous êtes le futur président de l'engin
vous êtes le président vous êtes le
président aux commandes elle n'existe
pas
je me contenterai elle se contente au
choc philippe d'assumer la
responsabilité de la mission de
préfiguration de l'autorité de rieux
l'arjel pour autorité de régulation des
jeux en ligne
elle s'est mise au travail tout de suite
dès la présentation du projet en conseil
des ministres nous sommes dans les
locaux de la mission de préfiguration
sont des locaux mis à disposition par le
ministère du budget les locaux sont
provisoires mais l'autorité fonctionne
déjà une dizaine de personnes a été
recruté nous faisons en sorte que le
jour où la loi sera promulguée le jour
où les décrets d'application seront
publiés bien l'autorité de régulation
sera en situation de fonctionner donc
nous partons d'une page blanche mais
parlementaires sont en train de l'écrire
et nous sous sa dictée législatives nous
mettons en place la future autorité de
régulation
ce sont eux qui détermineront sous
quelles conditions les opérateurs seront
autorisés avec un cahier des charges
précis mais qui ne sera connu qu'après
la promulgation de la loi
on parle d'une cinquantaine d'agrément a
priori d'ailleurs au moment de
l'ouverture du marché
l'effectif c'est la cinquantaine avait
ensuite pour une fois les délivrances
d'agrément effectué canton rond quand on
rentre en phase active de contrôle ont
été on va tendre vers les 80 d'accord ok
pour une durée de cinq ans si vous
remplissez les conditions pouvaient
obtenir la défense cet agrément donc
s'appelle sens les deux sens tout à fait
tout à fait ça va beaucoup dépendre des
conditions qui seront mises en place par
le cahier des charges mais il n'y a pas
de conditions de nombre d'opérateurs à
la base c'est plus et pendant que
l'arjel se mette en place que françois
trucy continue ses entretiens au sénat
le groupe socialiste a décidé lui aussi
de réaliser des auditions pour se faire
sa propre idée
c'est françois marc un sénateur
spécialiste des finances locales qui en
est chargé on n'est qu'au début de ce
processus
et ce n'est que dans quelques semaines
que la position définitive sera arrêtée
mais on peut considérer effectivement
que c'est pas un texte où il ya des
clivages considérables sur le plan
idéologique
les mois ont passé et en septembre enfin
l'europe fini par donner une position
claire l'arrêt santa casa affirme que
les états membres ont le choix ils
peuvent soit ouvrir leurs marchés
soit conserver leur monopole changement
radical
cet arrêt va donner des arguments à
l'opposition et faire naître une
alternative celle de conserver les
monopoles à la française le 7 octobre la
loi arrive à l'assemblée nationale nous
nous considérons que naturellement ce
n'est pas une bonne piste
il faut au contraire moderniser le
service public à la française des jeux
le pmu faut prendre une initiative
européenne pour renforcer la capacité de
contrôle et de sanction à cette échelle
pour faire respecter les dix stations il
faut réaffirmer haut et fort que les
jeux ce n'est pas une activité
économique ou commerciale comme les
autres d'ailleurs vous voudriez
conserver le monopole de la française
des jeux du pmu et des casinos
oui pour cent que en toute hypothèse
c'est à partir de cela qu'il faut agir
l'europe ne comprend pas à remettre en
cause le monopole
parce qu'il existe des sites illégaux
que la france doit faire concurrence à
ses choix ses sites illégaux en
légalisant une offre qui est dangereuse
pour nos concitoyens parce que sinon à
ce moment là je demande qu'on égalise le
cannabis en france une gauche revigorée
qui s'opposent frontalement au projet du
gouvernement
le gouvernement nous dit il y à une
réalité et d'une certaine manière c'est
un discours qui manque un peu de courage
il faut il céder cette réalité il vaut
mieux l'organiser plutôt que de devoir
les subir
mais d'une certaine façon ce que nous
explique aussi que la mesure qui est
prise au lieu de réguler cette réalité
laissé filer les choses qu'on met le
doigt dans un engrenage on voit bien
aussi que l'accélération de l'a27 de ce
projet de loi et vielles un événement et
le gouvernement s'en est pas caché il
faut être prêt il faut être prêt pour la
coupe du monde de football à dire en
juin prochain et il faut être prêt pour
que les prix médians puisse
immédiatement affiché aussi de la
publicité pour les opérateurs et pour
que les médias qui sont elles mêmes ont
acheté les droits tv sur ces
compétitions et vin puissent finalement
fait remonter la publicité leurs
recettes
la liste des gros industriels de
communication qui sont porteurs de ce
projet qui font du lobbying un lobbying
incroyables notamment près des
parlementaires se sont tous ceux qui
étaient le soir la victoire de nicolas
sarkozy au restaurant le fouquet's on a
c'est très clair vous les connaissez
tous et ces gens là il était ce soir-là
fêter la victoire de nicolas sarkozy est
là enfin ils vont avoir leur récompense
une loi pour les amis du président les
députés socialistes en ont même fait une
animation pour les journalistes
et c'est dans cette ambiance que
commence l'examen du texte en séance
publique ce que vous nous proposez ce
n'est pas simplement un texte à nola ce
que vous nous proposez c'est un
bouleversement de la législation
française sur les jeux les dans la ligne
de mire la prolifération des publicités
pour ses sites illégaux qui ont déferlé
sur internet sous les yeux du
gouvernement
est-ce que je dois vous citez le site de
l'om
l'ol est ce que je vais vous citer le
site du figaro est ce que je vais vous
citer l'ensemble des publicités qui ont
été faites pour des jeux en ligne
illégal depuis des mois alors vous nous
dites vous le dit l'urgence c'est le
protéger le consommateur et le parieur
contre cette offre illégale mais si
c'est ça votre motivation
l'urgence monsieur le ministre s'est
impliquée tout de suite à l'eau avec les
médias qu'elle vous donne pour que les
consommateurs soient réellement protégés
dans la tente peut-être d'une meilleure
législation mais si vous le faites pas
vous ne pouvez pas prendre prétexte de
cette situation pour essayer nous
imposer ce texte et pour essayer de nous
imposer cette loi
j'allais presque dire que l'arbre de
cette initiative avec monsieur aulas
cache la forêt de votre inertie ou de
votre impuissance islah du point de vue
de l'association nationale et du point
de vue de l'ordre public nous ne pouvons
pas l'accepter
merci chers collègues la parole est à
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
monsieur le président je voudrais réagir
rapidement aux propos de monsieur gorce
qui sont souvent excessive voire même
outrancier voire même outrancier je ne
vois pas ça n'existe pas la politique de
l'autruche total ça c'est le parti
socialiste sur beaucoup de sujets
notamment sur le sujet des jeux en ligne
je ne vois pas je ne sais pas qui lie à
des milliers de sites je ne sais pas
qu'il est bien difficile quand même de
contrecarrer les choses sur le plan
technique
alors que la législation n'existe pas
nous devons donc légiférer alors il ne
faut pas légiférer
donc il ne faut pas voir les sites
illégaux il faut laisser la leur
l'argent se faire et les courants
d'argent s'installer sans qu'on réagisse
tu sais ça que vous voulez moi je trouve
que c'est la politique du vide la pire
des politiques c'est selon lui la
politique de non régulation qui est la
pire des politiques c'est un début
d'examen qui assez tendue assez tendue
et il ressort de choses de ce débouché
début de débat puisque nous en sommes au
tout début de la discussion générale
c'est que lorsque nous évoquons la
question européenne
le fait que la cour de justice des
communautés européennes et rendu un
arrêt lui septembre après l'écriture du
texte gouvernement pour dire que les
monopoles publics sont autorisés le
gouvernement et la majorité sont très
mal à l'aise puisqu'ils ont pendant des
semaines et des semaines voire des mois
justifier leurs textes par une nécessité
européenne qui n'existe pas donc c'est
une mauvaise raison la deuxième mauvaise
raison c'est d'urgence à agir
puisqu'il nous explique qu'il ya des tas
de sites légaux alors que eux mêmes et
notamment le ministre du budget on
dispose des armes pour lutter conte fait
citer les illégaux et qui ne fait rien
on commence alors l'examen des
amendements l'un d'eux prévoit qu'une
fois la loi votée les opérateurs qui
continueront à proposer des paris
illégaux ne pourront plus obtenir
l'agrément de l'arjel leur site pourront
même être bloqué
le gros problème sur l'application ce
texte moi j'estime que le blocage des
sites sait on l'a encore vu dans des bas
depuis c'est quelque chose de très dur à
réaliser les sites de jolis ils ont des
moyens ils sont utilisés des sites
mermoud des sites miroirs ils seront ils
sauront trouver des techniques de
contournement si jamais on essaie de
bloquer leur cible
mais la question est de savoir à qui
donner ce pouvoir de bloquer un site un
juge ou bien à l'arjel la commission des
finances de l'assemblée nationale
souhaitait que ce soit l'arjel une
autorité administrative serait plus
rapide pour agir et donc plus efficace
qu'un juge avec une procédure plus
lourde
il s'est alors que ressurgit le spectre
de la loi hadopi d'abord c'est un souci
de cohérence
il ya quand même eu le précédent de la
loi hadopi qui a été censuré par le
conseil constitutionnel le 10 juin
dernier donc pourquoi pour quelle raison
parce que le conseil constitutionnel a
estimé qu'une autorité administrative
fut-elle indépendante ne pouvaient pas
suspendre l'accès à internet à nos
concitoyens
donc on allait avec l'amendement adopté
par la commission des finances se
remettre dans la même impasse juridique
et constitutionnel ça va on allait
confier à l'arjel une autorité
administrative en plus avec des tout
petits moyens on est lui confier la
responsabilité de couper l'accès à
internet
le conseil constitutionnel a bien dit
que c'était la liberté d'accès qui était
remis en cause par hadopi ce n'est pas
le cas ce n'est pas le cas avec le texte
que nous défendons aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
écoutez bien les chers collègues
aujourd'hui on propose simplement que
l'arjel
on propose simplement qu'à l'arjel
belote bloc des sites illégaux des sites
illégaux qui est pour
ok pour un tel effort les députés ont
finalement choisi d'avoir recours au
juge la procédure de blocage sera plus
lourde qu avec l'arjel mais ils évitent
ainsi d'éventuels recours l'article
dispositions de l'article 50 sont
maintenant adopter
mais c'est un député ump qui va déposé
l'amendement le plus encombrant pour les
opérateurs aujourd'hui illégaux yves
censi voudrait leur imposer une vraie
contrainte
en tout cas les empêcher d'avoir un
avantage sur les opérateurs qui se
créeront après la loi l'amendement 618
leur imposera de remettre leur compte
joueur à 0 pour pouvoir demander un
agrément à l'arjel ils devront prouver
qu'ils ont supprimé la liste de tous
leurs clients inscrits sur leur site
mais le ministre ne voit pas l'intérêt
d'aller si loin mais c'est ainsi la
procédure est très simple il faut
fournir la justification de la clôture
des comptes des joueurs et que cette
pièce cette justification
elle est indispensable pour avoir
l'accréditation si vous m'expliquez de
le contraire à soi voilà je ne je ne
comprends pas la cohérence de la
procédure
ceux qui sont avides de telle
manifestants en levant la main ceux qui
sont contre
l'amendement est adopté l'amendement est
voté avec les voix de l'opposition
au fil des heures le débat dépasse les
clivages droite gauche
le texte crée des divisions au sein de
la majorité on a une vraie confrontation
par exemple passionnante entre une
vision française qui fait référence au
droit romain d'ailleurs on a une vision
morale du jeu et on impose à chacun de
s'y adapter
qui n'est pas la même qu'une vision du
droit anglo saxon qui considère que ça
existe le jeu existe c'est une activité
humaine et que la loi n'est là que pour
organiser et éventuellement limiter les
choses on y est en plein dedans là on y
est en plein dedans et on sait très bien
qu'au niveau européen
c'est un vrai combat de doctrine
juridique qui s'opposent il est rentré
dans notre hémicycle
dans le cadre de ce débat plus qu'il ne
l'a jamais fait dans ce cas notre débat
je pense que beaucoup au départ quand on
parle des jeux d'argent et de hasard
beaucoup sans doute véritablement qu'on
arrive à ces niveaux de vision de la
société
après trois jours de débats la loi et
finalement adopté ce sera au tour du
sénat d'examiner le texte dans les mois
qui viennent
mais en attendant direction l'angleterre
le pays du jeu en europe
et revoilà unibet le site de paris
sportifs du parc des princes bienvenue
chez unibet
si nous avons plus de 180 personnes qui
travaillent pour unibet depuis le siège
de londres qui n'est pas le siège social
de la société car le siège social est
basé à malte mais qui est en fait le
water de la société des co-auteurs des
traders des commerciaux moyenne d'âge 25
ans plus de 38 nationalités représentées
c'est un peu une une petite mappemonde
oncle sorte concentrer sur sur quelques
mètres carrés et chez unibet
on a du mal à digérer cette remise à
zéro des comptes clients voté par
l'assemblée pour eux ça signifie
qu'entre le moment où la loi sera
promulguée et le moment où ils
obtiendront un agrément de l'arjel
il se passera plusieurs mois pendant
lesquels leur site sera tout simplement
inaccessible il ya un battement de 4 à 5
mois qui sur l'internet correspondait
année donc il est hors de question
évidemment que les gens soient soient
soient rendus inactifs pendant quatre ou
cinq mois si l'amendement 618 rester en
l'état
je pense que le conseil d'administration
remettrait certainement en cause la
décision qu'il a pris à de solliciter
une licence sur le marché français tout
à fait combien je ne vais pas vous dire
combien mais nous avons investi
massivement nous investissons
massivement et nous préparons cette
ouverture en nous positionnant sur des
partenariats stratégiques
mado que ce sera difficile de lui en
avait fait tout ça vous savez les
contrats tels qu'ils ont été signés
prévoit des clauses de sortie éventuelle
nous espérons seulement que nous ne
devrons pas les exercer et les mettre en
oeuvre
en réalité selon l'arjel le délai de
battement dont il parle serait dans mois
environ mais pendant qu'unibet réfléchi
au sénat une star fait son entrée
patrick bruel s'est lancé sur le marché
du poker avec le créateur de meetic
le site de rencontres vous êtes un bios
gagnant là quand quand j'ai pensé à un
site internet de poker il ya les poker
et si l'internet internet gt mais que
dalle dont je suis allé voir le meilleur
chemin vers soi je connais absolument
bien l'internet est pas du tout poker
donc sonné radio complémentaire des
raisons de faire ça dans la course est
bien discret c'est super
c'était pour en table les auditions se
sont passés le magna très convenable
jusqu'ici l'émeute et ils ont profité de
leur entretien avec françois trucy pour
se plaindre du fameux amendement 618 il
ya deux sujets le premier c'est qu'on
pense que si cet amendement est
maintenue la loi sera attaqué réattaquer
ce qui au fond arrange tout le monde
puisqu'on n'est pas très pressé de payer
des taxes à l'état français
la deuxième c'est que c'est le meilleur
moyen pour que les joueurs que les
opérateurs ont réussi à capter sur le
réseau partent sur des réseaux qui ne
demanderont pas de licence et donc c'est
une assiette réduite sur laquelle l'état
taxera c'est les psy je comprends très
bien qu'il dise que c'est compliqué
surtout ça peut faire rater
l'inscription même 2002 dans l'opérateur
si l'opérateur tout d'un coup a vu sa
clientèle se volatiliser bien ici il
prendra pas de licence il rentrera pas
dans la légalité et ça peut être une
très très préjudiciable à celles qui
veulent 13 légaux voilà
contre-productive par rapport à
l'objectif de la loi tout à fait
antinomique de l'objectif de la loi
le rapporteur cherche le compromis face
à des opérateurs qui commence à faire la
fine bouche au point de menacer de
finalement renoncer à demander un
agrément
car en plus de l'amendement 618 ce qui
chagrine beaucoup les opérateurs c'est
le niveau des taxes qu'il trouve un peu
trop élevé un grand hôtel parisien
conférence en anglais dans le texte
organisé par les opérateurs
tout le monde est là jean françois
vilotte de l'arjel le député yves censi
et françois trucy aussi dans toutes les
conversations le montant des taxes a
priori entre sept et demi et huit et
demi pour cent pour les paris sportifs
et hippiques
c'est beaucoup plus que dans les autres
pays européens
c'est presque pas d'hier du point de vue
commercial pour vous donner un exemple
en italie ou aussi l'état avait commencé
avec une taxation très fort du point de
vue des paris sportifs
on n'a pas été oubliée du point de vue
commercial jusqu'à ce qu'elle descende
au-dessus de 5% sur les ministres dont
8,8 et demi pour cent pour l'instant
c'est quoi alors c'est rébarbatif ça
veut dire que ça va empêcher certains de
venir
ça veut dire que ça va être un
investissement qu'il faudra faire
pendant les deux premières années
vu que le gouvernement a annoncé que au
bout des deux premières années il y aura
une révision si nécessaire du projet de
loi donc on espère qu'après on doit
changer la taxation des investissements
qu'on fera pour pouvoir être présent sur
marché possible aujourd'hui on se
prépare à entrer sur le sur le marché
français parce qu'on a construit un
projet pour ça mais c'est vrai qu'on
s'inquiète sur l'équation économique qui
va être possible et on attend surtout
beaucoup des pouvoirs publics sur la
lutte contre les sites illégaux parce
qu'avec des niveaux de fiscalité ten
si la lutte contre les sites illégaux
mais pas extrêmement performante le
marché légal va avoir du mal à se jeter
investir en attendant que le
gouvernement baisse les taxes investir
dans un nom dans une marque grâce à la
communication comme les monopoles
aujourd'hui les nouveaux opérateurs
légaux auront le droit de faire de la
publicité
un avantage sérieux par rapport aux
sites illégaux à qui ce sera interdite
mais la publicité c'est aussi le risque
de séduire de nouveaux joueurs
particulièrement les plus fragiles pour
en savoir plus
françois trucy a réuni les plus grands
spécialistes de la dépendance aux jeux
clairement on pense tous qui aura une
augmentation bien évidemment de des
patients a dit au jeu ses patients a dit
aux jeux sont ceux qui étaient
vulnérables aux addictions va pas dire
que c'est le jeu qui sera la folie
addictogène et simplement ça sera
révélateur des 10 % habituellement plus
vulnérables aux addictions que les
autres on va légaliser des publicités
qui sont pour le moment interdite
désistement et ça va voir l'impact
sûrement extrêmement important quand on
voit les sommes que sont prêts à
investir les opérateurs on se dit quand
ce sont des bons
commerciaux qu'ils attendent forcément
les retours positifs sur
l'investissement la loi n'a fait l'objet
d'aucune étude d'impact une étude de
santé publique est en cours mais elle ne
sera connue qu'en 2011
bien après le vote de la loi pour
françois trucy il faut donc prendre des
précautions loyer ou dans une loi s'y
attend merdes ans c'est que d'un côté
les exposer les motifs du ministre qui
donne la pensée du gouvernement du
mouvement sur un sujet du moment
aida à l'intérieur de ce hayatou il ya
l'expression vraiment de chose mis à
part il faut pas faire si il faut faire
ça c'est très grave important et quand
on le traduit dans la loi ça ce sas et
façon neutre en paix que article article
2 il faut mettre des taxes aux bains des
machins et on perd de vue
l'exposé des motifs l'esprit de la loire
et pourquoi on a fait noir lors déjà le
gouvernement peut pas dire j'ai fait la
loi je suis obligé parce que la
commission européenne m'emmerder
jusqu'aux yeux tant qu'on peut déjà pas
dire ça alors du coup au moins qu'on
dise les intérêts des joueurs les
mineurs des gens fragiles parce que ils
sont des milliers on les connaît pas et
sont comme tous les gens dans ces
situations là il parle pas et c'est
désastreux donc il faut penser à se
lasser sais pas qui lie la loi les jeux
se vendent uniquement de savoir qui va
gagner quoi et en quantité
il faut penser aux gens
casino de pougues les eaux dans la
nièvre un casinos du groupe tranchant
quatrième du secteur les casinos sont
l'un des trois piliers des anciens
monopoles
mais contrairement au pmu ou à la
française des jeux ils ne pourront pas
profiter de l'ouverture du marché
la loi n'autorise pas les jeux de casino
sur internet réputés trop addictif
résultats pour entrer sur le marché
georges tranche on devra faire du poker
même si ce n'est pas vraiment sa
spécialité
on accueille poker comme je relis donc
nous ne ferons que dufaux caire nous
avons un accord avec une plate forme je
dirais un peu internationale que nous
allons francisé à travers une licence
que je pense que nous obtiendrons et le
groupe tranchant offrira un poker
tranchante voilà
pas très enthousiaste georges tranchant
et pour cause la concurrence des sites
illégaux c'est un coup dur après tous
les efforts qu'ils ont dû fournir pour
protéger les joueurs fragiles
nous avons une liste d'interdits de 38
interdite
nous avons un contrôle très strict sur
son lit sont les mineurs et nous avons
un process de traitement de l'addiction
qui est réel qui existent alors que sur
internet à l'heure actuelle les binner
peut jouer il ya aucun contrôle des
débits aucun contrôle de la régularité
des jeux parce que sur internet vos
joffo caire qui vous dit que le gars qui
gère le site a pas tous les a pas toutes
les cartes
donc tout ça si vous voulez ça peut pas
continuer toute cette forme là
vous pouvez dès madame ramasser ces gars
là parce que ça n'arrête pas
elle va des galopeurs
j'ai eu tellement ses chaussures en
dépend manque de temps je sais m'arrêter
je sais enfin forme arrêté dans la
journée les jeux c'est
reste plusieurs jeunes survenir
je vous remercie vous regarde
malgré les garde-fous mis en place dans
les casinos les plus vulnérables ne
résiste pas on comprend alors
l'inquiétude des addictologues lorsque
le jeu d'argent sera disponible sur
internet à la maison à n'importe quelle
heure en janvier le projet arrive au
sénat
première étape la commission des
finances qui doit apporter ces
modifications
mais le projet a pris du retard et le
gouvernement veut aller vite car un
évènement important approche la coupe du
monde de football de juin 2010 un
calendrier très serré parce que la file
d'attenté des projets ou des
propositions devraient très importante
au parlement il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
l'activité de réforme donc donc c'est
compliqué et nous règne date butoir qui
est au fond la coupe du monde parce que
si le marché n'est pas organisée si on
n'a pas dit ce qui était légal ce qui
était illégal
on aura selon la queue de l'illégal pour
un moment donné où il y aura beaucoup
beaucoup de paris compte tenu de
l'engouement pour la coupe du monde de
football avec la coupe du monde c'est la
promesse de millions d'euros de gains
pour les opérateurs et pour l'état ce
jour là le ministre est auditionné par
la pollution
françois trucy en profite pour tester
une mesure à laquelle il tient
particulièrement la création d'un comité
consultatif des jeux
un comité consultatif des jeux qui
viendraient s'il est voté ainsi se
substituer à ce qui sera de mal la
situation si l'on n'y touche pas aux
organismes et ministères
chacun chargé d'une partie de la la
gouvernance des jeux mystères
d'intérieur qui veut pas lâcher ses
casinos ces cercles l'agriculture qui
surveille ses caisses et canassons 2
et le ministre des finances qui doit
forcément surveille le tout en
s'appuyant sur une police des jeux qui
au ministère de l'intérieur
non c'est pas possible ce ministre non
la réalité qu'on ait des forges donc
bien sûr on est d'accord je pense que
j'ai on est au chimiste suspense donc
si si l'espagne si si on est on est on
est venu nous on est d'accord sur la
proposition
moi je suis non plus que c'est une
mesure de simplification est essentiel
c'est le pouvoir donné demain à celle
que seul gouvernement
j'ai dit un organe consultatif complet
qui travaillent ensemble et au lieu que
chacun garde sa petite cuisine se sont
petit feu de son côté
al'approche du vote de la loi
françois marc le sénateur socialiste a
durci sa position son ongle d'attac
c'est le cadeau fiscal aux anciens
monopoles car pour compenser les pertes
liées à l'ouverture à la concurrence
la loi va baisser la fiscalité sur les
anciens monopoles et la mettre au même
niveau que les nouveaux opérateurs
la française des jeux et le pmu qui
était à 14 et 11 % passeront tous les
deux à huit aiguille % comme les autres
résultat un manque à gagner dans le
budget de l'état
donc on sait qu'on va perdre de la
recette actuellement c'est à peu près 5
milliards 6,2 recettes provenant des
jeux en ce qui concerne les rentrées
fiscales en ce qui concerne les budgets
la sécurité sociale en ce qui concerne
la redistribution vers le sport les
ferries p 5 milliards 6 avec les baisses
des taux de prélèvement on sait qu'il va
manquer probablement 2 milliards et donc
implicitement le gouvernement disant on
va rééquilibrer avec les nouvelles
recettes venant du jeu en ligne
on a le sentiment que l'attitude du
gouvernement est aujourd'hui incitatrice
au jeu puisque on veut récupérer au plus
vite les deux milliards de recettes
fiscales en commission des finances
face au ministre du budget et aux
membres de la commission habitué aux
chiffres il va mettre ce petit problème
sur le tapis quelques arguments pouvait
porter la matière parce que les 5
milliards je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans
la situation du budget d'état tel quel
et où ça veut dire que quiconque ici 5
milliards c'est pas rien et donc il faut
essayer de préserver cette
cette recette tout prix donc on va tout
faire aussi une maintenance et 5
milliard voire une développer moi je
pense que ça touchera en a plein de
scénarios je peux vous voulez vous plaît
à presser les problèmes de scénario sur
le volume l'aval de volume sur comment
ça se fait partie sur le point de lille
non parce que les jeux en réalité en
temps durs vont persister au même niveau
ça va dit les jeux en dur et qui rallie
la touche supplémentaire de jeux en
ligne qui permettra de revenir au même
étiage 9 auparavant sur l'ensemble des
joueurs du pl les calculs montrent qu'il
ya un manque à gagner pour l'état qui a
consisté qui est considérable on dit de
milliards qui sont normalement affectés
à des activités d'intérêt général
filière hippique et autres choses de ce
genre
il faut donc que les gens jouent plus ou
plus exactement qu'il y ait plus de gens
qui jouent et la sphère de la fiscalité
liée à ça si si vous avez une fiscalité
qui descend vous devez avoir une
politique encore plus agressive pour
capter une des consommateurs qui n'ont
des gens qui n'auraient jamais joué et
ça voyez tout est absolument lié le
niveau fiscal
l'attractivité du jeu la publicité c'est
pour moi d'ailleurs je ne le cache pas
la chose la plus choquant dans cette
affaire c'est qu'on va inciter les gens
qui n'auraient jamais joué à jouer par
la publicité massive et cela devient un
impératif
avec cette affaire fiscale jeu
au groupe socialiste du sénat on
peaufine la stratégie et les amendements
qui seront déposés
l'article 3 on a l'interdiction des
sites de jeux aux mineurs
c'est à dire que l'idée qui est qui est
mise en avant s'est passé pas de
créer une nouvelle interdiction mais
c'est de voir s'il n'est pas possible
d'enrichir le dispositif pour que
l'interdiction soit véritablement retour
en commission des finances qui doit
maintenant modifié le texte voté par
l'assemblée nationale
ce passage en commission est devenue une
étape clé dans la procédure législative
c'est là que va se décider l'essentiel
des modifications sur la loi françois
trucy fait voter le comité consultatif
des jeux
il propose également d'alourdir les
sanctions contre les opérateurs illégaux
qui se montait à 30000 euros dans le
texte de l'assemblée
il s'agit dans cet article 48 coma hier
de faire que le l'amendé porté à 100
mille euros pour le projet il s'agit de
la publicité illégale pour détecter les
sites illégaux
le rapporteur propose de mettre en place
des autorités spécialisées parlant de
même que dans la répression de la
pédopornographie
la gendarmerie a dû moderniser ses
méthodes et faire de la chasse
informatique avec des agents spécialisés
de même il faut donner à la possibilité
à l'arjel d'avoir des moyens de repérage
des illégaux et repérer des lego ça veut
dire qu'il ya un certain nombre d'agents
qui doivent se spécialiser
il est prévu dans cet article cet
amendement est un autre d'ailleurs un
peu plus loin de confier une de ces
fonctions là à d'éloigner pas à tous les
douaniers bien des douaniers on leur
dira d'ailleurs qui est pas mal entendu
c'est la mode le mot de
cyberpatrouilleurs est évoqué je suis
favorable aux douaniers la seule chose
qui nous permettrait de viser la télé
lois sont promulguées pour la coupe du
monde ça serait que le travail du sénat
soit apprécié à sa route va le faire par
l'assemblée nationale
et quel but
le bon de voter conforme si l'assemblée
nationale l'examen en commission des
finances de l'assemblée
votre conforme on économise tout le
retour au sénat la commission paritaire
et à ce moment là je pense honnêtement
qu'on est dans les pouilles que le la
pour le voir peut être oublié y encore
beaucoup de travail à faire mais elle
prête pour le muguet pour le 10 juin le
23 février 2010 la loi arrive enfin en
séance publique sous le regard attentif
de jean françois vilotte
c'est un jour important que veut voir le
texte enrichi par dans la haute
assemblée
donc c'est un moment que nous attendions
après les débats en commission des
finances parce que vous en êtes à
l'arjel vous êtes prêts écoutez nous
sommes prêts en tout cas nous serons
lorsque la loi a été promulguée donc les
effectifs maintenant on crut l'aîné des
process les documents qu'attendront les
opérateurs pour déposer leurs dossiers
sont également prêts sont nos peu de
temps en ligne donc le travail a été
effectué en temps masqué et en parallèle
mon travail parlementaire c'est
aujourd'hui on n'entend que des
incitations aller vite voilà polémique
faut aller vite faut aller vite mais on
n'entend pas tellement d'arguments de
fonds nous expliquant que si on ne le
fait pas on met la france en péril on
n'entend pas ça parce qu'ils savent bien
que l'argument ne serait pas tellement
recevra n'aurait pas tellement de
fondement l'ordre du jour appelle la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale relative à
l'ouverture à la concurrence et à la
régulation du secteur des jeux d'argent
et de hasard en ligne
alors dans la discussion générale et
bien apparent l'état monsieur eric
woerth ministre du budget et des comptes
publics de la fonction publique et de la
réforme de l'état
nous examinons aujourd'hui donc un texte
qui porte sur un sujet difficile sur un
sujet évidemment sensible des jeux
d'argent il s'agit d'argent il s'agit de
hasard de jeu donc c'est nécessairement
un sujet particulièrement sensible
si l'état qu'il soit renouvelé est
parvenu jusqu'ici à remplir correctement
ses devoirs en matière d'ordre public et
de sécurité publique
il n'en est pas de même pour si tous à
la santé publique dans ce domaine
sensible
nous sommes actuellement consterné par
l'absence quasi totale de recherche et
de travaux publics par une prise en
compte officiel de l'addiction j'ai
vraiment trop molle jusqu'à aujourd'hui
en définitive le texte vise surtout à
servir au plus vite les intérêts des
nouveaux opérateurs aller très vite pour
être prêt à toucher la manne
publicitaire de la coupe du monde de
football 2010 tandis qu on entend depuis
des semaines et qu'on vient à nouveau
d'entendre ici
voilà l'une des obsessions du projet
gouvernemental
il y a des centaines de millions à
gagner pour les opérateurs qui attendent
impatiemment que le fromage tombe le
texte que les sénateurs examinent ton
séance publique
c'est celui qui a été amendé par la
commission des finances le gouvernement
et la commission ont déjà insérés leur
amélioration
l'opposition va tenté de rejeter le
texte en le renvoyant en commission des
finances
la parole est à monsieur trucy monsieur
le rapporteur
monsieur le président et cher collègue
et moi je suis atterré parce que je
prends les choses très au sérieux
alors donc que nous n'avons pas été à la
hauteur la tâche en commission des
finances
alors mon propos et surtout d'y répondre
puisque il faut que je vous apporte une
certaine preuve de notre bonne volonté
au moins si l'on de notre talent que les
136 audition que j'ai conduite
personnellement sont insuffisantes et
mal utilisé et eu 300 personnes écoutées
pour rien donc pour rien plus de 400
heures perdues ou rendez compte
quel gaspillage parce qu'elle est-il
tout au contraire de cette notion que le
travail en amont a été effectué
correctement et qu'il est indispensable
maintenant d'en débattre
la majorité de la commission des
finances où demande de rejeter cette
motion
dans ce cas là je mets aux voix
la motion de renvoi en commission de
monsieur bérit débat que ceux qui sont
david adopté veuille bien le manifestant
devant dame un avis contraire allez la
motion n'est pas adopté n'hésitez de bon
sens ne sont pas forcément celles qui
sont retenus on impute préélectorale
élections régionales dans trois semaines
puis élection au sénat l'année prochaine
il est clair qu'aujourd'hui la majorité
n'est pas dingue disposition d'esprit à
se mettre en travers des volonté
élyséenne et donc toutes nos initiatives
même si elles sont parfois considéré
comme de bon sens pour nos collègues
soit au moment du vote la sentiment
qu'on aimerait début de l'examen des
amendements pour l'essentiel ceux de
l'opposition qui dézingue gardait pour
la séance publique
mais ils sont rejetés les uns après les
autres car l'objectif du gouvernement
est de modifier le texte le moins
possible pour essayer d'obtenir le
fameux vote conforme de l'assemblée le
78 de françois marc deux avis
défavorables
il n'est pas adopté le 79 de roland
courteau il n'est pas adopté 76
il n'est pas adopté
je vais mettre aux voix l'ensemble du
projet de loi y at il des demandes
d'explications de vote françois marc
vous avez la parole à des points noirs
de ce débat parlementaire au sénat
c'est que nous n'avons pas été entendus
sur la nécessité aujourd'hui de protéger
les jeunes de protéger les gens les plus
modestes
face à cette déferlante publicitaire qui
va dans les semaines qui viennent à
paraître dans le paysage les mesures de
protection des mineurs des joueurs
excessifs ont du mal à convaincre
mais le ministre s'en défend
il ya pour les mineurs la nécessité de
fournir un certain nombre de pièces et
notamment de photocopie certifiée et
c'est donc ça tout sera fait c'est plus
lourd les pour les opérateurs c'est un
travail mais c'est normal c'est sur une
protection et renvoyé des photocopie de
la carte d'identité envoyait photocopie
de leur carte d'identité pour ouvrir un
compte certifié avec toute une toute une
procédure qui sera vérifiée par l'arjel
et parlent et par l'opérateur lui-même
carnets comptables est redevable donc
c'est c'est dans le cahier des charges
pour les interdits de jeu c'est indique
jeu c'est pareil
c'est pareil ils n'auront pas de listing
les les des listes y glisser à
l'intérieur donc y aura transmission
ministère l'intérieur
la plupart des dispositions de cette loi
qui sont destinés à protéger le joueur
sont des dispositions dont les comment
dirais-je la mise en oeuvre des pans de
l'opérateur c'est alors vous avez
l'obligation de dire votre âge
on va dire que ce soit extrêmement
contraignant vous avez l'obligation pour
l'opérateur de signaler les cas dans
lesquels les gens se mettent à trop
jouer ce qui est supposé de leur part
une très grande vertu que sans doute ils
ont mais on peut pas dire que ce soit
extrêmement contraignant tout ça sur
l'ensemble du projet de loi
je vous rappelle que l'avis de la
commission est favorable à vis du
gouvernement est favorable il va être
procédé au scrutin public
la majorité des sénateurs se range
derrière l'avis du rapporteur et du
gouvernement pour l'adoption 181 contre
le sénat a adopté et la séance est levée
on a évité tous les tous les pièges
c'est dire qu'il ya aucun cailloux sur
la route qui permet de c'était
l'objectif depuis de longs mois de faire
que la copie du ceva soit acceptable par
l'assemblée nationale
si c'est pas du tout dans la religion en
mutuelle du l'assemblée nationale donnez
un coup de mou pillon comme ça sur les
sur les thèmes du sénat or pourtant si
on veut
sauver le père ouvrier que la loi sur
formules liées par un couple vivant
c'était indispensable donc il a fallu
effectivement quelquefois on a fait des
petits sacrifices
il a fallu que le texte soit le plus
recevable ils sont bien quoi chacun
s'est beaucoup investi dans ce selon ce
texte qui est pas un texte anodin ça
peut apparaître parfois un peu
anecdotique par rapport au sujet de la
crise de la relance économique et des
tous ces sujets qui nous occupe beaucoup
et c'est pas du tout anodin c'est quand
même un ouverture de deux jeux il ya
beaucoup d'argent c'est c'est le jeu
c'est tout cela et donc le fait qu'on
puisse c'est internet donc le fait qu'on
puisse ouvrir qu'elles sont maîtrisés
c'est un point très important
l'ouverture maîtrisée du marché des jeux
est en marche alors que beaucoup
d'inconnues persistent les mesures
précises que devront mettre en place les
opérateurs pour entrer sur le nouveau
marché le niveau exact des taxes sur les
jeux en ligne et surtout l'impact corps
à cette loi sur la population française
c'est le bouleversement d'un système
vieux de deux siècles qui n'aura pas
résisté au développement d'internet
une petite révolution dans une
indifférence quasi générale
regardez dans la presse on n'en parle
pas dans la presse on parle de temps en
temps d'un opérateur de jeux qui fait
ceci ou cela mais la question du début
des jeux en ligne il n'y a pas d'article
dans la presse ou très très très très
peu ce n'est pas un sujet ça n'intéresse
pas les gens parce qu'il ne voit pas le
problème c'est tout il vous ne voit pas
la question et ils ne se rendent pas
compte du danger je suis certain que les
conséquences sociales seront tout à fait
désastreuse j'espère que je me trompe
vous savez que de ça
j'espère que je me trompe